y nicaragua no respeta sus compromisos
con la democracia esto es lo que
concluyeron 25 de los 34 estados que
integran la organización de estados
américanos que firmaron una resolución
en la crisis tan al presidente daniel
ortega a que acepte una misión para
llevar a cabo reformas electorales en
cumplimiento con la carta interamericana
ocho países se abstuvieron entre los que
se encuentran bolivia mexico argentina y
honduras
el consejo permanente de la organización
de estados américanos resuelve hacer un
llamamiento al gobierno de nicaragua
para que permita el retorno inmediato de
los órganos internacionales de derechos
humanos como la comisión interamericana
de derechos humanos y la oficina del
alto comisionado de las naciones unidas
para los derechos humanos la resolución
pide a nicaragua que se permita la
realización de elecciones imparciales
como observación internacional creíble
esto luego de que en los comicios
presidenciales de noviembre en los que
ortega fue reelecto no participó la
oposición ya sea porque sus candidatos
fueron detenidos o se vieron obligados a
exiliarse la oea también pidió al
presidente nicaragüense liberar a todos
los opositores detenidos instar al
gobierno de nicaragua a que con carácter
urgente y como primera medida
en libertad a todos los presos políticos
nicaragua pidió su salida de la oea
después de que ésta asegurara que los
comicios no fueron libres ni
transparentes dicha salida es un proceso
que puede demorar hasta dos años en los
cuales las obligaciones de la nación
centroamericana continúan intactos